Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. At 912am on Tuesday, September 11, 2001, 24-year-old Wells Crowther left a voicemail for his mother. Speaking calmly, he said, Mum, this is Wells. I wanted you to know that I'm okay.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您在应用程序或我们网站上本集节目的节目说明。2001年9月11日星期二上午9点12分，24岁的韦尔斯·克劳瑟给他的母亲留了一段语音留言。他平静地说：“妈妈，我是韦尔斯。我想让你知道我很好。”
Nine minutes earlier, a hijacked commercial aircraft had been deliberately flown into the South Tower of New York City's World Trade Center, marking the second major catastrophe that morning. 17 minutes earlier, its neighbouring twin skyscraper, the North Tower, had been similarly hit. The 110-story South Tower was struck between floors 77 and 85, several floors beneath the office where Wells Crowther worked as an equities trader. After Wells phoned his mother to let her know he was alive, he raced down to the sky lobby on the 78th floor. The tip of the plane's wing had torn through the space, leaving burning carnage in its wake.
九分钟前，一架被劫持的商用飞机被蓄意撞向纽约世界贸易中心南塔，这是当天上午发生的第二起重大灾难。17分钟前，其相邻的孪生摩天大楼北塔也遭到了类似的撞击。110层高的南塔在77层到85层之间被撞，就在韦尔斯·克劳瑟担任股票交易员的办公室下方几层。在韦尔斯给母亲打电话告知他还活着之后，他冲向了78层的空中大厅。飞机机翼的尖端撕裂了那个空间，留下了燃烧的残骸。
A group of dazed and frightened survivors huddled at a bank of damaged elevators, nursing injuries ranging from burns and broken bones to cracked ribs and punctured lungs. Wells immediately took control of the chaotic situation and directed the survivors to an emergency stairwell that led to the ground level. Carrying one woman on his back, he guided the group down over a dozen floors before urging them to go on without him. He then headed back. He then headed back upstairs. By the time Wells made it back to the 78th floor, the area was overcome by thick, dark smoke. He stripped it down to his t-shirt, pulled a red bandana from his pocket, and secured it over his nose and mouth so that he could breathe. Wells navigated through the
一群惊魂未定、恐惧万分的幸存者蜷缩在受损的电梯旁，忍受着从烧伤、骨折到肋骨断裂和肺部穿孔等各种伤痛。韦尔斯立即控制了混乱的局面，引导幸存者前往通往地面的紧急楼梯间。他背着一名妇女，引导这群人走下了十几层楼，然后催促他们不要管他继续前进。他随后折返。他随后折返楼上。当韦尔斯回到78层时，该区域已被浓重的黑烟笼罩。他脱掉外衣只剩下T恤，从口袋里掏出一块红头巾，系在鼻子上以保持呼吸。韦尔斯穿过
debris until he came across more injured survivors. He retrieved extinguishers to put out the surrounding flames before administering first aid. He then calmly and he then calmly and announced, everyone who can stand, stand now. If you can help others, do so. Wells led the group to the stairwell. As they rushed out onto the street, Wells remained in the tower to continue helping others. At 9.59 a.m., 56 minutes after the plane's initial impact, the South Tower collapsed. It was followed 29 minutes later by the North Tower. In the aftermath of 9-11, stories from survivors surfaced about a mysterious man who had sacrificed his life to rescue them in the South Tower. They recalled the distinct red bandana he had worn across his face, which earned him the title, The Man in the Red Bandana.
残骸，直到他遇到更多受伤的幸存者。他取来灭火器扑灭周围的火焰，然后进行急救。他随后冷静地宣布：“所有能站起来的人，现在站起来。如果你能帮助别人，就去做。”韦尔斯带领这群人走向楼梯间。当他们冲向街道时，韦尔斯留在塔内继续帮助他人。上午9点59分，在飞机最初撞击56分钟后，南塔倒塌了。29分钟后，北塔也随之倒塌。9-11事件发生后，幸存者中流传着关于一名神秘男子的故事，他为了营救南塔中的人们而牺牲了自己的生命。他们回忆起他脸上戴着的那条独特的红头巾，这为他赢得了“红头巾男子”的称号。
When Alison Crowther read an article about the brave young man in the New York Times, she immediately knew who it was. As a child, Wells Krauthar watched his father Jeff get ready for church. Jeff kept a comb handy, which he wrapped in a blue bandana tucked into his right hip pocket. One day, Jeff gave his son his own bandana in his preferred color of red. It quickly became Wells' trademark. He wore it under his sports uniforms in high school and had it on him throughout his travels after graduation. As he entered the corporate world,
当艾莉森·克劳瑟在《纽约时报》上读到关于这位勇敢年轻人的文章时，她立刻知道那是谁。小时候，韦尔斯·克劳瑟看着父亲杰夫准备去教堂。杰夫随身带着一把梳子，用一条蓝头巾包着，塞在右后裤兜里。有一天，杰夫把自己的头巾送给了儿子，颜色是他最喜欢的红色。这很快成了韦尔斯的标志。他在高中时把头巾戴在运动服里面，毕业后的旅行中也一直带着它。当他进入企业界时，
Wells kept his lucky bandana at his desk or in his back right pocket of his pants. When his colleagues asked why, Wells would reply, With this red bandana, I'm going to change the world. When shown photographs of Wells Crowther, the survivors confirmed he was the man
韦尔斯把他的幸运头巾放在办公桌上或裤子的右后兜里。当同事问起原因时，韦尔斯会回答：“有了这条红头巾，我要改变世界。”当看到韦尔斯·克劳瑟的照片时，幸存者们确认他就是那个
who had saved them. Wells' remains were recovered six months in to the extensive cleanup of Ground Zero. He was found alongside the bodies of firefighters and emergency services personnel who had been operating a command centre in the South Tower's ground lobby. It was believed that Wells had joined the other rescuers as they were preparing to free those trapped above before everything came crashing down.
救了他们的人。韦尔斯的遗体在“零地带”大规模清理工作进行了六个月后被发现。他被发现时与消防员和紧急服务人员的遗体在一起，这些人当时正在南塔地面大厅运营一个指挥中心。据信，韦尔斯在其他救援人员准备营救被困在上方的人员时加入了他们，随后一切都坍塌了。
Courage, duty and care had been a major part of Wells' character throughout his life. While he loved working in the World Trade Centre, he hoped to one day get a job helping others directly. In the meantime, he was a fully trained volunteer firefighter and used those skills to save as many as 18 lives in the South Tower. Speaking about Wells, one survivor said, People can live 100 years and not have the compassion,
勇气、责任和关怀贯穿了韦尔斯的一生，是他性格的重要组成部分。虽然他热爱在世界贸易中心的工作，但他希望有一天能找到一份直接帮助他人的工作。在此期间，他是一名训练有素的志愿消防员，并利用这些技能在南塔挽救了多达18人的生命。谈到韦尔斯，一位幸存者说：“人们可以活100岁，却未必有那种同情心，
the wherewithal, to do what he did. Stories of Wells' actions on 9-11 helped his loved ones heal after the tragedy. They established the Wells Crouther Charity Trust, an organisation that awards young people who served their communities. They hoped that Wells' story would inspire others to be more altruistic in their day-to-day lives. His mother Allison said,
有那种能力去做他所做的事。”韦尔斯在9-11事件中的事迹帮助他的亲人在悲剧后得到了治愈。他们成立了韦尔斯·克劳瑟慈善信托基金，这是一个奖励为社区服务的年轻人的组织。他们希望韦尔斯的故事能激励他人在日常生活中更加无私。他的母亲艾莉森说：
We took a great peace in knowing that Wells, up until the end, was being very courageous, doing what he wanted to do. He must have felt that, very fulfilled that day, knowing he was helping others. In the wake of 9-11, an organisation was founded called the World Trade Centre United Families Group, which aimed to help those affected by the attacks reconstruct their lives. The group was primarily for the families of those who died in the tragedy, but survivors were also encouraged to join and seek support. The group's online forum offered individuals a place where they could speak to fellow survivors who understood firsthand what they
“我们感到极大的安慰，因为知道韦尔斯直到最后都非常勇敢，做着他想做的事。那天他一定感到非常满足，因为知道自己在帮助别人。”9-11事件后，一个名为“世界贸易中心联合家庭小组”的组织成立了，旨在帮助受袭击影响的人们重建生活。该小组主要针对在悲剧中遇难者的家属，但也鼓励幸存者加入并寻求支持。该小组的在线论坛为个人提供了一个可以与同样亲身经历过这些的幸存者交流的地方，
were going through. Inside their online community, survivors were met with empathy, understanding, and camaraderie as they bonded over their collective trauma. They shared their harrowing stories and helped each other overcome immense feelings of grief, guilt and regret. On Tuesday, May 13, 2003, 20 months after 9-11, a post was uploaded on the Survivors Forum by a new user. It read, I am only starting to feel the consequences now, despite having tried so hard to put it all behind me. I don't sleep. I see and hear the images and sounds. I'm moody. My stress and anxiety have skyrocketed, and a variety of other things. For so long I pretended to be okay.
他们正在经历什么。在他们的在线社区内，幸存者们在共同的创伤中产生了共鸣，获得了同情、理解和友谊。他们分享了令人揪心的故事，并互相帮助克服了巨大的悲伤、内疚和遗憾。2003年5月13日星期二，即9-11事件发生20个月后，一名新用户在幸存者论坛上发布了一篇帖子。文中写道：“尽管我努力想把这一切抛在脑后，但我现在才开始感受到后果。我睡不着。我看到并听到那些画面和声音。我情绪低落。我的压力和焦虑急剧上升，还有各种其他事情。这么久以来，我一直假装自己很好。”
that it is now hard to admit this is actually happening. I think I need to talk to someone about this and tell my story, but I don't see how I will manage that. Going through it once was more than enough. The user signed their post off with their name, Tanya Head. Tanya's post elicited supportive comments from other survivors who welcomed her to the group and encouraged her to share her story. They explained that their forum was a safe, non-judgmental and cathartic space to discuss all aspects of 9-11.
“以至于现在很难承认这一切真的在发生。我想找人谈谈这件事并讲述我的故事，但我不知道该怎么做。经历过一次已经足够了。”用户用她的名字“坦尼娅·海德”签署了帖子。坦尼娅的帖子引起了其他幸存者的支持性评论，他们欢迎她加入小组并鼓励她分享自己的故事。他们解释说，他们的论坛是一个安全、不评判且具有宣泄作用的空间，可以讨论9-11事件的方方面面。
Tanya was praised for the courage it took for her to come forward. The group awaited her opening up to them when she was ready. Tanya sporadically posted on the forum throughout May and June. She was 28 years old and originally from Spain, but had immigrated to the US during her youth. By 2001, she was working for the Distinguished Investment Management Company Merrill Lynch in the World Trade Centre's South Tower. Like others, she was struggling immensely in the aftermath of the attack. While she maintained a happy disposition in real life, internally she was suffering.
坦尼娅站出来所表现出的勇气受到了赞扬。小组等待着她准备好向他们敞开心扉。坦尼娅在5月和6月期间零星地在论坛上发帖。她当时28岁，原籍西班牙，但在年轻时移民到了美国。到2001年，她在世界贸易中心南塔的杰出投资管理公司美林证券工作。和其他人一样，她在袭击发生后也在极度挣扎。虽然她在现实生活中保持着快乐的姿态，但内心却在受苦。
She rarely left her apartment, and whenever she closed her eyes, she was plagued by images of crashing planes, crumbling buildings, and mangled bodies. Little things, like the sounds of planes overhead or the flicker of a candle flame, triggered frightening memories. Depression and panic attacks prevented Tanya from returning to work and had contributed to her gaining weight. While she was grateful for the support the other survivors showed her, she wasn't ready to share her full story just yet. In June, members of the forum organized a visit to the remains of the Twin Towers.
她很少离开公寓，每当闭上眼睛，她就会被飞机坠毁、建筑倒塌和残缺尸体的画面所困扰。一些小事，比如头顶飞机的声音或烛光的闪烁，都会触发可怕的记忆。抑郁和恐慌发作使坦尼娅无法重返工作岗位，并导致她体重增加。虽然她很感激其他幸存者对她的支持，但她还没有准备好分享她的完整故事。6月，论坛成员组织了一次前往双子塔遗址的访问。
The area was cordoned off as clean-up efforts were still underway, but they intended to stand outside the barricade to reflect and grieve in each other's company. Tanya had initially accepted the invitation, but on the night before it was due to take place, she phoned one of the organisers to cancel. She said she was still fragile and wasn't ready. For survivors of 9-11, the road to recovery was fraught with difficulties. Priority was given to those who died and the loved ones they'd left behind. In contrast, survivors were regarded as the lucky ones and were expected to be grateful that they still had their lives.
该区域被封锁，因为清理工作仍在进行中，但他们打算站在路障外，在彼此的陪伴下反思和哀悼。坦尼娅最初接受了邀请，但在预定行程的前一天晚上，她打电话给其中一位组织者取消了行程。她说她仍然很脆弱，还没有准备好。对于9-11事件的幸存者来说，康复之路充满了困难。优先考虑的是那些遇难者和他们留下的亲人。相比之下，幸存者被视为幸运儿，并被期望对他们仍然活着感到感激。
Some felt their suffering was overlooked or misunderstood by their general public, media and government. This feeling was amplified when an invite-only event was held at Ground Zero to mark the two-year anniversary of the attacks, and some of the survivors were turned away. In fact, none of the survivors had ever been permitted to access the site, unlike the families of those who had passed. Efforts to arrange a private tour were also denied, adding to ongoing feelings of invisibility for many survivors. Survivors vented their growing frustrations online,
有些人觉得他们的痛苦被公众、媒体和政府忽视或误解了。当在“零地带”举行仅限受邀者参加的活动以纪念袭击两周年，而一些幸存者被拒之门外时，这种感觉被放大了。事实上，与遇难者家属不同，没有任何幸存者被允许进入该地点。安排私人参观的努力也遭到了拒绝，这加剧了许多幸存者持续存在的被忽视感。幸存者在网上发泄他们日益增长的挫败感，
with a lot of their tensions directed towards the World Trade Center United Families Group. One morning, Tanya had logged into the forum and suggested the two groups split. They could create their own online support group, completely independent of the United Families. Tanya wrote, I think it's important that we stick together. Other users agreed, and by that afternoon, they had established the World Trade Center Survivors Forum. Within their new online space, users were able to open up like a, never before. The switch appeared to liberate Tanya, who began posting more on this forum than
他们将许多不满指向了“世界贸易中心联合家庭小组”。一天早上，坦尼娅登录论坛并建议两个小组分开。他们可以创建自己的在线支持小组，完全独立于“联合家庭小组”。坦尼娅写道：“我认为我们团结一致很重要。”其他用户表示同意，到那天下午，他们已经建立了“世界贸易中心幸存者论坛”。在他们新的在线空间里，用户能够以前所未有的方式敞开心扉。这种转变似乎解放了坦尼娅，她开始在这个论坛上发帖，比
she had the original. Eventually, she felt comfortable to recount her personal story of survival. Tanya said she was chairing a meeting in a conference room on the 96th floor of the South Tower when the first plane hit the North Tower. Tanya and her colleagues flocked to the windows where they observed the large smoking crater the aircraft had left in the neighbouring skyscraper. Survivors of the impact emerged from the debris and clung to the crater's edge, waving and crying out for help as explosive flames inched closer behind them. Facing a terrible fiery death, the survivors took matters into their own hands. Some attempted to scale down the building to safety, while others jumped or fell to their
在原来的论坛上发得更多。最终，她感到可以讲述她个人的生存故事了。坦尼娅说，当第一架飞机撞向北塔时，她正在南塔96层的一间会议室里主持会议。坦尼娅和她的同事们涌向窗户，观察到飞机在相邻的摩天大楼上留下的巨大冒烟弹坑。撞击的幸存者从残骸中出现，紧紧抓住弹坑边缘，挥手呼救，身后爆炸的火焰正步步紧逼。面对可怕的火海，幸存者们采取了自救措施。有些人试图爬下大楼逃生，而另一些人则跳下或坠落至
deaths. It was a confronting and distressing sight that would haunt Tanya forever. Tanya used her mobile phone to call her fiancé David, but the line was busy. A message was then relayed over the South Tower's public address system, urging occupants to stay put. The collision at the North Tower was believed to be an isolated incident and no one else was thought to be in any danger. Despite this, reassuring message, Tanya decided to leave. She made her way to the bank of elevators in the sky lobby on the 78th floor, where an anxious crowd had already formed. Panic said in, and the crowd began pushing closer to the elevator doors. Tanya recalled hearing one man yell,
死亡。这是一个令人震惊和痛苦的景象，将永远困扰着坦尼娅。坦尼娅用手机给她的未婚夫大卫打电话，但线路繁忙。随后，南塔的公共广播系统传出一条消息，敦促住户留在原地。北塔的碰撞被认为是一起孤立事件，没有人认为还有其他人处于危险之中。尽管有这条令人安心的消息，坦尼娅还是决定离开。她前往78层空中大厅的电梯组，那里已经聚集了一群焦虑的人群。恐慌袭来，人群开始向电梯门挤去。坦尼娅记得听到一名男子大喊：
Ladies, this is not the Titanic, it's not women and children first. Then, a hysterical voice cried out, There's another plane coming. There's another plane coming. The deafening roar of the approaching jet grew as it sped towards the South Tower. Within seconds, the plane made contact and erupted into a powerful fireball. Its wing shattered through the walls and collapsed the ceiling. Tanya felt a tremendous increase in pressure.
“女士们，这不是泰坦尼克号，不是女士和儿童优先。”然后，一个歇斯底里的声音喊道：“又有飞机来了！又有飞机来了！”随着喷气式飞机加速冲向南塔，震耳欲聋的轰鸣声越来越大。几秒钟内，飞机撞击并爆发成强大的火球。它的机翼击碎了墙壁，使天花板坍塌。坦尼娅感到压力剧增。
All the air in her lungs was sucked out. and for a moment, it seemed as though she was flying through the air. Then, everything went black. After recounting this experience to the World Trade Center Survivor's Forum, Tanya stopped. I find it very hard to talk about what happened afterward, she admitted. The community rallied around Tanya until she felt comfortable to open up a little more. She recalled that after being knocked unconscious by the impact of the South Tower collision, she woke up under a broken slab of marble that had once been part of a wall.
她肺里的空气全被抽干了，有一瞬间，她似乎在空中飞翔。然后，一切都陷入了黑暗。在向“世界贸易中心幸存者论坛”讲述了这段经历后，坦尼娅停了下来。“我发现很难谈论之后发生的事情，”她承认。社区成员团结在坦尼娅周围，直到她感到可以再多敞开心扉一点。她回忆说，在被南塔碰撞的冲击力震晕后，她在一块曾经是墙壁一部分的破碎大理石板下醒来。
Several fires illuminated the devastation around her. Lying alongside Tanya was a colleague who had been decapitated. Other mangled and charred bodies were scattered about while the weary voices of survivors cried out in the darkness. Smoke burned Tanya's lungs, thick dust almost blinded her, and pain radiated through her body. She agonised over the realization that this moment was going to be her last.
几处火光照亮了她周围的毁灭景象。躺在坦尼娅身边的是一位被斩首的同事。其他残缺不全、烧焦的尸体散落在周围，而幸存者疲惫的声音在黑暗中呼喊。烟雾灼烧着坦尼娅的肺，浓厚的灰尘几乎让她失明，疼痛在她体内蔓延。她痛苦地意识到，这一刻将是她的最后时刻。
Just as Tanya accepted her fate, someone began hitting her on the back. Each thud brought her immense pain. She begged the person to stop, only to realize that her clothes were on fire and a man was using a jacket to pat out the flames. A red bandana covered the lower half of his face, but Tanya could see his brown. eyes were kind. Just stay awake, he told her. The man said he was going to show Tanya the way out. Reassured by his calm presence, Tanya mustered the strength to pull herself out from under
就在坦尼娅接受命运时，有人开始拍打她的背。每一次重击都给她带来巨大的痛苦。她恳求那个人停下来，却意识到自己的衣服着火了，一个男人正用夹克拍打火焰。一条红头巾遮住了他脸的下半部分，但坦尼娅能看到他棕色的眼睛很善良。“保持清醒，”他告诉她。那个男人说他会给坦尼娅指明出路。被他平静的存在所安抚，坦尼娅鼓起勇气把自己从
the rubble. That's when she noticed that her right arm was severely burnt and hanging from her body by a threat of sinew. She tucked it into her jacket to keep it together. The man in the red bandana supported Tanya. Tanya as they climbed and crawled through the wreckage. Each movement brought Tanya agonizing pain, and she doubted she could go on. Her rescuer encouraged her by saying,
瓦砾中拉了出来。就在那时，她注意到她的右臂严重烧伤，仅靠一丝筋腱挂在身上。她把它塞进夹克里以保持完整。红头巾男子扶着坦尼娅，他们爬过残骸。每一次移动都给坦尼娅带来剧痛，她怀疑自己能否坚持下去。她的救命恩人鼓励她说：
Just keep moving. Along the way, the pair came across a badly burnt man gasping for air. Tanya knelt beside him, and he handed her something small and hot. It was a gold wedding ring inscribed with a woman. name and the word forever. Please give this to my wife, he begged. I'll find her and I'll give it to her, Tanya replied. Just as she placed the ring into her pocket, the man took his final breath.
“继续走。”一路上，两人遇到了一名被严重烧伤、喘着粗气的男子。坦尼娅跪在他身边，他递给她一件又小又热的东西。那是一枚金色的结婚戒指，上面刻着一个女人的名字和“永远”这个词。“请把它交给我的妻子，”他恳求道。“我会找到她并交给她的，”坦尼娅回答。就在她把戒指放进口袋时，那名男子咽下了最后一口气。
Tanya proceeded onwards with the man in the red bandana. They eventually reached the door to an emergency stairwell where the man placed his hand on Tanya's shoulder and said, go, you can do this. Tanya's mind raced with thoughts of her life, her family, her fiancé, and their upcoming wedding. Compelled to power on, she began her descent. The man helped her down each painful step
坦尼娅和红头巾男子继续前进。他们最终到达了紧急楼梯间的门，男人把手放在坦尼娅的肩膀上说：“走吧，你能做到。”坦尼娅的脑海中闪过关于她的生活、家人、未婚夫以及他们即将举行的婚礼的念头。在动力的驱使下，她开始下楼。男人帮她走下每一个痛苦的台阶，
until the smoke cleared and the rest of the way became clear. He removed his bandana, looked at Tanya resolutely and reassured her that she would be safe. Just keep going down, I have to go back up and help other people, he said, before heading back towards the wrecked sky lobby. Tanya hobbled down until the pain, exhaustion and blood loss became too much and she passed out. She was soon stirred awake by a firefighter who told her, We're leaving here together.
直到烟雾散去，前方的路变得清晰。他摘下头巾，坚定地看着坦尼娅，向她保证她会安全。“继续往下走，我得回去救其他人，”他说完，便转身朝受损的空中大厅走去。坦尼娅蹒跚而行，直到疼痛、疲惫和失血让她无法承受，昏了过去。她很快被一名消防员唤醒，他对她说：“我们一起离开这里。”
He carried Tanya down the remaining 20 floors and out onto the street. They had barely made it out when the ground began to shake. The thunderous sound of crushing concrete and metal filled the air. People all around began running away in panic. Tanya was thrust under a fire truck just as the South Tower collapsed behind her. Her next memory was waking in hospital five days later. Her arm had been reattached, but she would only ever have partial usage. of it, and the burn scars would remain. Tanya's distraught parents were by her side.
他背着坦尼娅走下了剩下的20层楼，来到街上。他们刚出来，地面就开始震动。混凝土和金属破碎的雷鸣声充斥着空气。周围的人们开始惊慌失措地逃跑。就在南塔在她身后倒塌时，坦尼娅被推到了一辆消防车下。她的下一个记忆是五天后在医院醒来。她的手臂已经接好，但她只能部分使用它，烧伤的疤痕也会留下。坦尼娅心烦意乱的父母守在她身边。
Where's Dave? She asked. Tanya's fiancéi David worked for a consulting firm on the 100th floor of the North Tower. She would come to learn that he didn't make it. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Case File to continue to deliver quality content. Tanya Head's survival was nothing short of incredible. In the North Tower, the plane had hit between floors 93 and 98 in a manner that decimated all forms of escape. At the crash side and above, over 1,300 people died. There were no survivors. It might be. It might be might have been a similar outcome in the South Tower had it not been for two special circumstances.
“戴夫在哪里？”她问。坦尼娅的未婚夫大卫在北塔100层的一家咨询公司工作。她后来得知他没能活下来。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持“案件档案”继续提供优质内容。坦尼娅·海德的幸存简直不可思议。在北塔，飞机撞击在93层到98层之间，摧毁了所有逃生方式。在撞击点及上方，超过1300人死亡。没有幸存者。如果不是因为两个特殊情况，南塔的结果可能也差不多。
Firstly, the emergency stairwell was far enough from the impact zone to remain usable. Secondly, the man in the red bandana, Wells Crowther. Survivor Ling Young described Wells as their guardian angel, saying, Without him, we would be sitting there waiting until the building came down. Tanya Head was one of the lucky few saved by Wells that day, but the loss of her fiancé in the North Tower made her experience uniquely devastating. She was the only person to be both a tower survivor of the 9-11 attack
首先，紧急楼梯间距离撞击区足够远，可以继续使用。其次，红头巾男子，韦尔斯·克劳瑟。幸存者凌永（音译）将韦尔斯描述为他们的守护天使，说：“没有他，我们就会坐在那里等着大楼倒塌。”坦尼娅·海德是那天被韦尔斯救出的少数幸运儿之一，但她在北塔失去未婚夫的经历使她倍感痛苦。她是唯一一个既是9-11袭击的塔楼幸存者，
and a bereaved family member of a life it claimed. Tanya's extraordinary story soon caught the attention of Jerry Bogas, a planning director for the New York Metropolitan Transportation Council, Jerry had fled from the North Tower before it collapsed, but several members of his team had stayed behind and died. In the devastating aftermath, Jerry spearheaded several in-person survivors' meetings throughout the city as a means of support. It was through these that he learned about Tanya Head and was in awe of her story. He reached out to Tanya online and the two bonded over their shared ordeal. Like Jerry, Tanya was using her struggles as motivation to help others.
又是遇难者家属的人。坦尼娅非凡的故事很快引起了纽约大都会交通委员会规划主任杰里·博加斯的注意。杰里在北塔倒塌前逃了出来，但他团队中的几名成员留在了里面并遇难了。在毁灭性的余波中，杰里在全市范围内带头组织了几次幸存者面对面会议，作为一种支持手段。正是通过这些会议，他了解到了坦尼娅·海德，并对她的故事感到敬畏。他在网上联系了坦尼娅，两人因共同的磨难而建立了联系。像杰里一样，坦尼娅利用她的挣扎作为帮助他人的动力。
She said it gave her the will to live. Jerry was struck by Tanya's optimism and resilience despite all she had lost. He invited her to attend one of his meetings set for Saturday, January 24, 2004, and she willingly accepted. While no one in any of the Survivor's time, circles had met Tanya in real life yet, everyone knew her story, and she'd become somewhat of a celebrity among them. But Tanya didn't relish the attention. When she attended Jerry Bogas's meeting, the other guests found her to be unassuming and shy. While she was responsive and grateful for their support, she was happy to sit quietly as the meeting took place around her.
她说这给了她活下去的意志。杰里被坦尼娅尽管失去了一切却依然保持的乐观和韧性所打动。他邀请她参加定于2004年1月24日星期六举行的会议，她欣然接受。虽然幸存者圈子里还没有人在现实生活中见过坦尼娅，但每个人都知道她的故事，她已成为他们中的名人。但坦尼娅并不享受这种关注。当她参加杰里·博加斯的会议时，其他客人发现她谦逊而害羞。虽然她对他们的支持做出了回应并表示感谢，但她很高兴在会议进行时安静地坐着。
Jerry Bogas spoke of his vision to create a non-profit organization specifically for 9-11 survivors that would help empower individuals to find renewed purpose. The organization intended to implement a Day of Recognition titled Survivors Day and aimed to finally get survivors' access to Ground Zero. From there, they hoped to provide input on a memorial for the site. The group settled on a name. The World Trade Centre Survivors Network. Tanya suggested that the network joined forces with her online group, the Survivors Forum.
杰里·博加斯谈到了他的愿景，即建立一个专门针对9-11幸存者的非营利组织，帮助赋能个人找到新的目标。该组织打算实施一个名为“幸存者日”的认可日，并旨在最终让幸存者进入“零地带”。从那里，他们希望为该地点的纪念碑提供意见。小组确定了一个名字：“世界贸易中心幸存者网络”。坦尼娅建议该网络与她的在线小组“幸存者论坛”联手。
Not only would they have more political clout with greater numbers, they could also share the arduous task of identifying and reaching out to the thousands of people who had survived 9-11 to offer their support. By the end of the meeting, Tenya had come out of her shell and was fiercely determined. That night, she sat at her computer contacting an array of people who could help the network and its members. Six weeks later, Tanya sent an email to the Survivor's Network announcing good news. She had contacted the World Trade Center site supervisor, and after years of inexplicable rejection, she had successfully negotiated a private visit to Ground Zero.
他们不仅能通过更多的人数获得更大的政治影响力，还能分担识别并联系成千上万名9-11幸存者以提供支持的艰巨任务。会议结束时，坦尼娅已经走出了她的外壳，变得非常坚定。那天晚上，她坐在电脑前联系了一系列可以帮助该网络及其成员的人。六周后，坦尼娅给幸存者网络发了一封电子邮件，宣布了好消息。她已经联系了世界贸易中心现场主管，经过多年的莫名拒绝，她成功协商了一次前往“零地带”的私人访问。
The group was elated. The tour took place on Friday, May 14, 2004, with 20 survivors opting to take part. Unlike those around her, this was not Tanya's first visit to Ground Zero. Because her fiancé had died in the attacks, she had gone on one of the first private tours held for family members of the deceased. This new opportunity allowed Tanya to focus on. on comforting her companions who were eternally thankful for what she had done. After being granted access to the 16-acre site, the survivors were permitted to descend a ramp
小组欣喜若狂。参观于2004年5月14日星期五进行，20名幸存者选择参加。与周围的人不同，这不是坦尼娅第一次访问“零地带”。因为她的未婚夫在袭击中丧生，她曾参加过为遇难者家属举办的首批私人参观之一。这个新的机会让坦尼娅能够专注于安慰她的同伴，他们对她所做的一切永远心存感激。在获得进入16英亩场地的许可后，幸存者们被允许走下一条坡道
to the bottom of the pits where each tower had once stood. It was a confronting and somber experience that fuelled varied emotions. Some felt a sense of peace and closure, while others grappled with oppressive sadness. Tanya spoke of feeling David's presence all around her. In stories about her fiancé, Tanya detailed how they had fortuitously met outside the World Trade Center in February 1999. The pair had finished work in their respective towers when they headed out onto the street. Heavy rain was pelting across the city, so Tanya beeline for a cab idling nearby. Just as she went to hop in,
到达每座塔楼曾经矗立的坑底。这是一种令人面对和沉重的经历，激发了复杂的情绪。有些人感到平静和解脱，而另一些人则在压抑的悲伤中挣扎。坦尼娅谈到感觉到大卫的存在就在她周围。在关于她未婚夫的故事中，坦尼娅详细描述了他们是如何在1999年2月在世界贸易中心外偶然相遇的。两人在各自的塔楼完成工作后，走到了街上。大雨倾盆而下，所以坦尼娅直奔附近一辆空闲的出租车。就在她准备跳进去时，
A man slipped into the back seat from the opposite side. He was handsome with a radiant smile and striking blue-green eyes. He offered her the cab on the condition that she take his business card and call him. His name was David and at 24 years old, he was two years younger than Tanya and worked for a consulting firm in the North Tower. Offended by his bold arrogance, Tanya had no intention of calling him. Two weeks later, Tanya was in the World Trade Centre's concourse when David tapped her on the shoulder and remarked, I never should have let you have that cab because you never called. Flustered, Tanya agreed to a quick coffee date.
一个男人从对面滑进了后座。他很英俊，笑容灿烂，有着迷人的蓝绿色眼睛。他提出把出租车让给她，条件是她必须拿走他的名片并给他打电话。他的名字叫大卫，24岁，比坦尼娅小两岁，在北塔的一家咨询公司工作。坦尼娅对他的大胆傲慢感到冒犯，根本没打算给他打电话。两周后，坦尼娅在世界贸易中心的大厅里，大卫拍了拍她的肩膀说：“我真不该让你坐那辆出租车，因为你从来没打过电话。”慌乱中，坦尼娅同意了一次快速的咖啡约会。
The pair spent the next three hours chatting. David spoke of his love for the outdoors, his selfless charity work and his plans for the future. Tanya told him about her privileged upbringing in Barcelona that led to her business tycoon father uprooting her family to the US. Despite her inherited entitlements and wealth, Tanya grew to be a humble and compassionate person with an enthusiasm for social activism. At age 17, she was recruited by the number one international management school in the world. She was accepted early into Harvard University for an
两人接下来的三个小时都在聊天。大卫谈到了他对户外活动的热爱、他无私的慈善工作以及他对未来的计划。坦尼娅告诉他她在巴塞罗那的优越成长环境，这导致她身为商业大亨的父亲将全家搬到了美国。尽管拥有继承的权利和财富，坦尼娅还是成长为一个谦逊且富有同情心的人，对社会活动充满热情。17岁时，她被世界排名第一的国际管理学院录取。她被哈佛大学提前录取，攻读
undergraduate degree before earning a graduate business degree from Stanford University. This helped her secure a job with Merrill Lynch in the South Tower. When Tanya had to pull herself away for a work meeting, David insisted, I have to see you again. A whirlwind fairy tale romance followed. According to Tanya, David was the type of guy who everybody loved. Nicknamed Big Dave, he was a stickler for time, could recite all the lines from the film Braveheart, and had a habit of misplacing things. But what Tanya loved most about David was his sensitive side.
本科学位，随后获得了斯坦福大学的研究生商业学位。这帮助她在南塔的美林证券找到了一份工作。当坦尼娅不得不离开去参加工作会议时，大卫坚持说：“我必须再见到你。”一段旋风般的童话爱情随之而来。据坦尼娅说，大卫是那种每个人都喜欢的人。绰号“大戴夫”的他对时间要求严格，能背诵电影《勇敢的心》中的所有台词，并且有乱放东西的习惯。但坦尼娅最爱大卫的是他敏感的一面。
He always put others first, as evident in his volunteer work at a soup kitchen. He was also a hopeless romantic, the type to serenade Tanya in public and recite poetry to her. He loved children and wanted several of his own. To Tanya, he was almost too good to be true. Given that money wasn't a problem for either of them, the couple were able to travel overseas and buy a beach house in the Hamptons. They eventually settled into a luxurious New York apartment with a golden retriever they named Delvis.
他总是把别人放在第一位，这在他于施粥处的志愿工作中显而易见。他也是一个无可救药的浪漫主义者，那种会在公共场合为坦尼娅小夜曲并为她朗诵诗歌的人。他喜欢孩子，想要几个自己的孩子。对坦尼娅来说，他几乎好得不真实。鉴于他们两人都不缺钱，这对夫妇能够去海外旅行，并在汉普顿买了一栋海滨别墅。他们最终定居在纽约的一间豪华公寓里，养了一只名叫“德尔维斯”的金毛猎犬。
Their love story culminated in a dinner at the top of the North Tower, where David proposed. They planned a high-society wedding with 500 guests for early October 2001, but the preparations weren't smooth sailing. Tanya found herself exasperated by the influence David's mother had on every decision, which resulted in the couple arguing almost every day. Just as Tanya was starting to have doubts, she returned home to their apartment to find a trail of rose petals leading to the dining room. There, David was waiting in a coconut bra and grass
他们的爱情故事在北塔顶层的一顿晚餐中达到高潮，大卫在那里求婚。他们计划在2001年10月初举行一场有500名宾客的社会名流婚礼，但准备工作并不顺利。坦尼娅发现自己对大卫母亲在每一个决定上的影响力感到恼火，这导致这对夫妇几乎每天都在争吵。就在坦尼娅开始产生怀疑时，她回到公寓，发现一条玫瑰花瓣铺成的小路通向餐厅。在那里，大卫穿着椰子壳胸罩和草
skirt, dancing the hula. A spread of Hawaiian dishes adorned the table, all prepped by David himself. He revealed that he had purchased them two tickets to Hawaii, leaving the next day. The pair spent the next few days in a grand resort in Maui typically reserved for celebrities. While there, David surprised Tanya with an elaborate and picturesque wedding ceremony he had organized entirely by himself, right down to her dress. It was a magical experience, but the pair still intended to go through with their official wedding in New York. On Tuesday, September 11, 2001, Tanya arrived at work in a tense mood. She and David had argued that morning. over another petty grievance, something she would come to regret as their final encounter.
裙，跳着草裙舞等着她。桌上摆满了夏威夷菜肴，全是大卫亲手准备的。他透露他已经买了去夏威夷的两张票，第二天就出发。两人在毛伊岛一家通常只接待名人的豪华度假村度过了接下来的几天。在那里，大卫用一场他完全独自组织的精致而如画的婚礼仪式给了坦尼娅一个惊喜，甚至连她的婚纱都是他准备的。这是一次神奇的经历，但两人仍然打算在纽约举行正式婚礼。2001年9月11日星期二，坦尼娅带着紧张的心情上班。她和大卫那天早上因为
Yet, it was thoughts of him and their upcoming wedding that had given her the courage to escape from the South Tower. Writing about it on the Survivor's Forum, she recalled, I wanted to wear that white dress and swear my love for him in front of friends and family. I wanted to have his children. I believed to wear that white dress. I believed to wear my love for him in front of friends and family. I I believe today that he stopped to give me the strength to get out of there on his way to heaven. Years later, as Tanya stood in the pits where the Twin Towers once stood, she reminisced on these moments. Among the flowers and cards other survivors had placed, she left a letter to David that
另一件琐事吵了一架，这是她后来作为他们最后一次见面而感到后悔的事情。然而，正是对他的思念和他们即将举行的婚礼给了她逃离南塔的勇气。她在幸存者论坛上写道：“我想穿上那件白色的婚纱，在朋友和家人面前发誓对他的爱。我想生他的孩子。我相信穿上那件白色的婚纱。我相信在朋友和家人面前发誓对他的爱。我相信今天是他停下来给了我力量，让我在去天堂的路上逃离那里。”多年后，当坦尼娅站在双子塔曾经矗立的坑边时，她回忆起这些时刻。在其他幸存者放置的花束和卡片中，她留下了一封给大卫的信，
detailed how much she loved and missed him. At the end of the survivors' visit to Ground Zero, the group encircled Tanya and showered her with gratitude. Thanks to her, they had taken a much-needed step forward on their healing journey. Tanya smiled kindly, but later confided in a frant that the visit had been very hard for her. Seeing the pain of her fellow survivors was heart-wrenching, and she was now grieving for David even more. She intended to visit David's childhood town where a memorial garden was constructed in his honor. Although Tanya explained that it would be hard to see his name etched in stone and she knew she'd cry for days afterwards, she was just glad he was being recognized. She appreciated
详细描述了她有多么爱他、多么想念他。在幸存者访问“零地带”结束时，小组围住坦尼娅，向她表达了感激之情。多亏了她，他们在治愈之旅中迈出了急需的一步。坦尼娅亲切地笑了笑，但后来私下告诉一位朋友，这次访问对她来说非常艰难。看到其他幸存者的痛苦令人心碎，她现在为大卫感到更加悲伤。她打算去大卫的家乡，那里为纪念他建造了一个纪念花园。虽然坦尼娅解释说看到他的名字刻在石头上会很痛苦，而且她知道之后会哭上好几天，但她很高兴他得到了认可。她很感激
David's family, whom she stayed close with and visited often. Tanya vented to her friend about another issue she was dealing with. Anyone who applied to join the Survivor's Forum was automatically accepted, as the group trusted in people's good faith. Yet, one member began making some suspicious posts that led the group to deduce he wasn't a 9-11 survivor at all, but had made up his story for attention. Tanya expressed discomfort that the fraudster had been reading their personal posts. He had since been banned and policies were enacted that led Tanya to believe it wouldn't happen again. She wrote to her friend. I mean, who would want to fake being a world trade centre survivor, right? Tanya was happy to sacrifice her time to continue advocating for the
大卫的家人，她与他们保持着密切联系并经常拜访。坦尼娅向她的朋友发泄了她正在处理的另一个问题。任何申请加入“幸存者论坛”的人都会被自动接受，因为小组相信人们的善意。然而，一名成员开始发布一些可疑的帖子，导致小组推断他根本不是9-11幸存者，而是为了博取关注而编造了自己的故事。坦尼娅对骗子一直在阅读他们的个人帖子感到不安。他此后已被禁止，并制定了政策，让坦尼娅相信这种情况不会再发生。她写信给她的朋友：“我的意思是，谁会想假装成世界贸易中心的幸存者，对吧？”坦尼娅很高兴牺牲自己的时间继续为
World Trade Centre Survivors Network. She was a regular at the in-person meetings, where she drew in others with her unbreakable spirit. They applauded as she detailed all the things she was doing on their behalf. In addition to managing the online forum, she organized Survivor's Speakers' events, held writing workshops, met with publishers who could assist in producing books on their stories, and plotted a documentary with a filmmaker. She used her own money to print t-shirts branded with the Survivor's Network logo, hosted lighthearted outings throughout the city, and held fundraisers. She even found a specialist trauma. She even found a specialist trauma. expert to lead therapy sessions.
“世界贸易中心幸存者网络”进行倡导。她是面对面会议的常客，以她坚不可摧的精神吸引了其他人。当她详细介绍她代表他们所做的一切时，他们鼓掌喝彩。除了管理在线论坛外，她还组织了幸存者演讲活动、举办写作研讨会、会见可以协助制作关于他们故事书籍的出版商，并与电影制作人策划了一部纪录片。她用自己的钱印刷印有幸存者网络标志的T恤，在全市举办轻松的郊游活动，并举行筹款活动。她甚至找到了一位专家创伤。她甚至找到了一位专家创伤。专家来主持治疗课程。
Tanya did all of this with infectious joy that made survivors forget their pain whenever they were in her presence. They couldn't help but be impressed with how well she was coping compared to them. With her radiant warmth and willingness to lead, Tanya quickly became the face of the 9-11 survivors. While most survivors struggled to describe or remember what they had witnessed that day, Tanya could repeat her story in mesmerizing detail. Survivor's stories typically featured one or two key elements.
坦尼娅带着感染力十足的快乐完成了这一切，使幸存者们在她在场时忘记了痛苦。他们不禁对她与他们相比表现出的良好应对能力印象深刻。凭借她灿烂的温暖和领导意愿，坦尼娅很快成为了9-11幸存者的代言人。虽然大多数幸存者难以描述或回忆起那天他们所目睹的一切，但坦尼娅可以以令人着迷的细节重复她的故事。幸存者的故事通常包含一两个关键要素。
They either saw the plane's impact, were inside one of the towers at the time, had witnessed the falling bodies, or had run from the crashing buildings. Tanya had experienced at all. Her severely scarred, withered right arm was a testament to the horrors she endured. Not only was hers a truly remarkable unique account, it also featured the lauded 9-11 hero, Wells Crowther. Yet, Tanya never tried to one-up the other survivors or act like she had it worse. To her, all their
他们要么看到了飞机的撞击，要么当时在其中一座塔楼内，目睹了坠落的尸体，或者从倒塌的建筑中逃离。坦尼娅全都经历过。她严重疤痕化、萎缩的右臂证明了她所忍受的恐怖。她的叙述不仅是一个真正非凡且独特的记录，还包含了备受赞誉的9-11英雄韦尔斯·克劳瑟。然而，坦尼娅从未试图超越其他幸存者或表现得好像她更惨。对她来说，他们所有的
stories were equally valid. She didn't hog the spotlight, tried a profit off of her story, or bask in media attention. In fact, she seemed to seem to see. somewhat intimidated by it. When she was approached for interviews, she was often reluctant to participate. She was just happy and comfortable to remain an honoured figure within the close-knit survivor circles. And for all her work, she never asked for anything in return. All she wanted was a sense of appreciation and to see others follow in her lead. Yet, even Tanya had her bad days, where she was uncharacteristically sullen. Sometimes she disappeared for days at a time while ignoring calls and messages. She confided in a friend that she wasn't rebounding nearly as successfully as she let on.
故事同样有效。她没有独占聚光灯，试图从她的故事中获利，或沉浸在媒体的关注中。事实上，她似乎对这些感到有些畏惧。当有人找她采访时，她往往不愿参加。她只是很高兴并乐于保持紧密联系的幸存者圈子中受人尊敬的人物。对于她所做的一切工作，她从未要求任何回报。她想要的只是被认可的感觉，并看到其他人追随她的脚步。然而，即使是坦尼娅也有糟糕的日子，那时她会表现出反常的阴郁。有时她会消失几天，同时忽略电话和信息。她私下告诉一位朋友，她的恢复情况并不像她表现出的那样成功。
Antidepressants prescribed by her therapist did a little to curb recurring nightmares of 9-11. She barely slept and some days she couldn't muster the energy to leave her apartment. Whenever she was inside a building, she feared a plane would hit. Air travel was intimidating as she imagined hijackers were on board. She was also worried that she would never find a man she loved as much as David. Tanya told her friend she kept these feelings to herself because she didn't want to burden anyone, confiding. It seems no one cares about how much I suffered, what I saw. She lamented that she should have died, explaining,
她的治疗师开的抗抑郁药对抑制9-11的反复噩梦几乎没有作用。她几乎睡不着觉，有些日子她甚至没有精力离开公寓。每当她在建筑物内时，她就担心飞机撞击。航空旅行令她感到恐惧，因为她想象劫机者就在机上。她还担心自己永远找不到像爱大卫那样爱她的男人。坦尼娅告诉她的朋友，她把这些感受藏在心里，因为她不想给任何人增加负担，她感叹道：“似乎没有人关心我受了多少苦，我看到了什么。”她哀叹自己本该死去，并解释说：
Now I can't find meaning in anything I do. All of this makes me mad and it makes me wonder what it is that I'm doing here. Why is it that I continue to be haunted by the images of that day? I'm so tired of trying to make sense of any of this, of trying to cope with my situation. Over the coming months, Tanya's appearances became sporadic, both online and in real life. When the third anniversary of 9-11 arrived, Tanya forewent expectations to attend Ground Zero, telling other members of the Survivor's Network that she would be spending time with David's parents instead. They were private people who had chosen not to appear at any 9-11-related public events.
现在我无法在所做的任何事情中找到意义。这一切让我感到愤怒，也让我怀疑自己在这里到底在做什么。为什么我依然会被那一天的画面所困扰？我厌倦了试图去理解这一切，厌倦了试图去应对我的处境。在接下来的几个月里，坦尼娅（Tanya）无论是在网上还是现实生活中，露面都变得断断续续。当“9·11”三周年纪念日到来时，坦尼娅没有像大家预期的那样去往“零地带”（Ground Zero），而是告诉“幸存者网络”（Survivor's Network）的其他成员，她要和戴维（David）的父母待在一起。他们是非常低调的人，选择不参加任何与“9·11”相关的公开活动。
It was in respect to their privacy that Tanya hadn't yet revealed David's last name to anyone. In January 2005, Tanya volunteered to take a humanitarian trip to Southeast Asia to help those who had recently been impacted by the devastating Indian Ocean earthquake and tsunami which claimed over 200,000 lives. Tanya kept the Survivors Forum updated on her experience by sending nearly 30,000. page long writings that covered everything from the meals she ate to the work she did in villages delivering supplies and rebuilding infrastructure. Those 10 days were eye-opening for tenure. She wrote of the personal growth she went through seeing other survivors coming to terms with the death and
正是出于对他们隐私的尊重，坦尼娅此前一直没有向任何人透露戴维的姓氏。2005年1月，坦尼娅主动请缨参加了一次前往东南亚的人道主义救援之旅，去帮助那些近期受到印度洋大地震和海啸影响的人们，那场灾难夺走了超过20万人的生命。坦尼娅通过发送近3万字的长文，向“幸存者论坛”更新她的经历，内容涵盖了她吃的每一顿饭，以及她在村庄里分发物资和重建基础设施的工作。那10天对坦尼娅来说大开眼界。她写下了自己在看到其他幸存者接受周围的死亡和
destruction around them. It also answered the question that she had been agonising over, why did she survive? Now she understood. It wasn't to pick up the pieces and try and return to her old life. That could never happen. It was to help others. In the month after Tanya returned to the States, she appeared at a meetup for the Survivors Network. It had been a while since the group had seen her and she was greeted with a standing ovation and a round of applause. Her overseas human humanitarian work had boosted Tanya's enthusiasm, and she seemed to be back to her normal, energetic self. She threw herself back into her advocacy work for the network, becoming its co-chair alongside its founder, Jerry Bogas. She worked into the night making calls and sending emails,
毁灭时所经历的个人成长。这也回答了她一直以来苦苦思索的问题：为什么她能幸存下来？现在她明白了。不是为了收拾残局并试图回到旧生活。那永远不可能实现。而是为了帮助他人。在坦尼娅回到美国后的一个月里，她参加了“幸存者网络”的一次聚会。团队已经有一段时间没见到她了，她受到了起立鼓掌和欢呼的欢迎。她在海外的人道主义工作提振了坦尼娅的热情，她似乎又回到了那个正常、充满活力的自己。她全身心地投入到为网络所做的倡导工作中，与创始人杰里·博加斯（Jerry Bogas）一起担任联合主席。她工作到深夜，打着电话，发着邮件，
reaching out to bureaucrats and other influential New Yorkers until they got the recognition they sought. Plans and policies were starting to be implemented, with 9-11 survivors in mind. Tanya also kept her promise by working to identify the man who entrusted his wedding ring to her before the collapse of the South Tower. After months of devoted research, Tanya finally tracked down his widow. Tanya gave her the ring in private, with no fuss or media attention. While she was happy to talk broadly about the poignant experience,
联系官僚和其他有影响力的纽约人，直到他们获得了他们所寻求的认可。计划和政策开始实施，并充分考虑了“9·11”幸存者的需求。坦尼娅也信守承诺，努力寻找那个在南塔倒塌前将结婚戒指托付给她的男人。经过几个月专注的调查，坦尼娅终于找到了他的遗孀。坦尼娅私下里把戒指交给了她，没有大张旗鼓，也没有引起媒体的注意。虽然她很乐意广泛地谈论这段感人的经历，
Out of respect for the woman's privacy, Tanya refused to divulge her or her husband's name. For all of Tanya's hard work, one of her biggest tasks was yet to come. After the remains of the Twin Towers were cleared, a set of 37 steps that had once connected the skyscraper's plaza to the street below remained. During the attacks, hundreds of survivors had used these stairs as their path to freedom. The stairs had managed to withstand both the collapse of the buildings and the subsequent demolition work. Referred to as Survivor's Staircase, they were set to be removed as part of the redevelopment. At the behest of the survivors, Tanya successfully campaigned for the steps to remain untouched and become a feature of the memorial. When an offer was put forward seeking volunteers to lead walking tours of Ground Zero,
但出于对那位女士隐私的尊重，坦尼娅拒绝透露她或她丈夫的名字。尽管坦尼娅付出了巨大的努力，但她最大的任务之一还在后面。在双子塔的残骸被清理干净后，留下了37级台阶，这些台阶曾经连接着摩天大楼的广场和下方的街道。在袭击期间，数百名幸存者曾利用这些楼梯作为通往自由的路径。这些楼梯成功地经受住了建筑物的倒塌和随后的拆除工作。这些楼梯被称为“幸存者阶梯”（Survivor's Staircase），原定作为重建工程的一部分被拆除。在幸存者的要求下，坦尼娅成功地开展了运动，使这些台阶得以保留，并成为纪念馆的一个特色。当有人提出招募志愿者带领“零地带”徒步游览时，
Tanya was the first to respond. With her positive reputation, she was the ideal candidate and was invited to try out. She carried out several test tours, during which she guided tourists through the 9-11 site, while detailing the history of the Twin Towers, the subsequent attacks, and her escape. On her own volition, Tanya told her followers about David and showed them her scarred arm. Her story left listeners in tears. Tanya's story encapsulated both the tragedy and triumph of New York on 9-11. She was therefore asked to lead a walking tour for three of New York's most powerful politicians,
坦尼娅是第一个响应的。凭借良好的声誉，她是理想的人选，并受邀进行试讲。她进行了几次测试游览，期间她带领游客参观“9·11”遗址，同时详细讲述了双子塔的历史、随后的袭击以及她的逃生经历。坦尼娅自愿向追随者讲述了戴维的故事，并向他们展示了她伤痕累累的手臂。她的故事让听众热泪盈眶。坦尼娅的故事概括了“9·11”当天纽约的悲剧与胜利。因此，她被邀请为纽约三位最有权势的政治家进行徒步导览，
Governor George Pataki, Mayor Michael Bloomberg, and former Mayor Rudy Giuliani. Although Tanya was delighted by the recognition, she was hesitant to a accept. She told a friend there was so much at stake. She'd only ever told her story to other survivors, tourists, or at small-scale private functions. This would be a major press event with dignitaries, camera crews and journalists, which would thrust Tanya into the international spotlight. She wasn't sure she was ready and feared she'd mess everything up. Tanya's friend reassured her, saying, they wouldn't have picked you if they didn't believe in you. Case File will be back shortly.
分别是乔治·帕塔基（George Pataki）州长、迈克尔·布隆伯格（Michael Bloomberg）市长和前市长鲁迪·朱利安尼（Rudy Giuliani）。尽管坦尼娅对这种认可感到高兴，但她犹豫是否要接受。她告诉一位朋友，这关系重大。她以前只向其他幸存者、游客或在小规模的私人活动中讲述过她的故事。这将是一场有政要、摄制组和记者参加的重大新闻活动，这将把坦尼娅推向国际聚光灯下。她不确定自己是否准备好了，并担心会把一切搞砸。坦尼娅的朋友安慰她说，如果他们不信任你，就不会选择你。案件档案（Case File）稍后回来。
Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. The walking tour was scheduled to take place on Friday, September 9, 2005. That morning, Tanya Head was. a nervous rack. Jittery and teary-eyed, she considered pulling the plug entirely. Her supporters had never seen her like this. They assumed she was grappling with painful memories and felt intimidated by her esteemed guests. That wasn't the case. Tanya explained she was overwrought
感谢您通过收听本期节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本期节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持了CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。徒步游览定于2005年9月9日星期五进行。那天早上，坦尼娅·黑德（Tanya Head）紧张得要命。她焦躁不安，泪流满面，甚至考虑完全取消行程。她的支持者从未见过她这样。他们以为她是在与痛苦的记忆作斗争，并对尊贵的客人感到畏惧。事实并非如此。坦尼娅解释说，她是因为
by the large media presence and didn't want to answer any of their questions. Her fellow survivors gave her comfort and encouragement, reminding her how important the publicity was to the network's vision. This would mark the first time a 9-11 survivor was featured front and centre at a major event. By the time the tour was scheduled to begin, Tanya managed to calm her nerves. At the preceding press conference, Mayor Michael Bloomberg stated, It's heartening to know that the September 11th story will be told with accuracy, with honesty, and with a great heart. With a newfound sense of confidence, Tanya then led the way while recounting her miraculous story
媒体在场人数众多而感到不知所措，不想回答他们的任何问题。她的幸存者同伴给予她安慰和鼓励，提醒她这次宣传对网络愿景的重要性。这将标志着“9·11”幸存者首次在重大活动中处于核心位置。当游览预定开始时，坦尼娅设法平复了紧张的情绪。在随后的新闻发布会上，迈克尔·布隆伯格市长表示：“得知‘9·11’的故事将以准确、诚实和一颗伟大的心被讲述，这令人振奋。”带着一种新获得的自信，坦尼娅随后带路，同时讲述了她奇迹般的故事
of survival. Those in attendance were captivated, with Governor George Pataki remarking that they were very grateful and proud of Tanya. After the tour, the press bombarded them. Tanya with questions and interview requests, but her entourage kept them at bay, saying Tanya was too exhausted to engage at that time. Even without Tanya's direct participation, her story made headlines, and it soon came to the attention of Wells Crowther's parents, Jeff and Allison. The couple reached out to Tanya wanting to meet her in person, but Tanya was reluctant.
幸存的故事。在场的人都被迷住了，乔治·帕塔基州长表示他们非常感谢坦尼娅，并为她感到骄傲。游览结束后，媒体蜂拥而至，向坦尼娅提出问题和采访请求，但她的随行人员将他们挡在外面，称坦尼娅当时太累了，无法参与。即使没有坦尼娅的直接参与，她的故事也登上了头条，并很快引起了韦尔斯·克劳瑟（Wells Crowther）的父母杰夫（Jeff）和艾莉森（Allison）的注意。这对夫妇联系了坦尼娅，想亲自见她，但坦尼娅很勉强。
She claimed that family members of 9-11 victims asked too many questions and pried for specific details, which forced her to dredge up painful memories. When she couldn't give them the answers they sought, they often turned hostile towards her. One encounter had triggered her to have a panic attack. But by early 2006, Tanya had a change of heart. She was willing to reconsider the Crowther's role. request on one condition. Their meeting was to be private and confidential with no media or anyone else present. The Krauthers happily agreed. They were just delighted to hear from another person
她声称“9·11”受害者的家属问了太多问题，打听具体的细节，这迫使她挖掘痛苦的记忆。当她无法给出他们想要的答案时，他们往往会对她产生敌意。有一次遭遇曾引发了她的恐慌发作。但到了2006年初，坦尼娅改变了主意。她愿意重新考虑克劳瑟夫妇的请求，但有一个条件。他们的会面必须是私下且保密的，不能有媒体或其他人在场。克劳瑟夫妇欣然同意。他们只是很高兴能从另一个
who owed their life to their son. On the day of the meeting, Tanya was once again overwhelmed with anxiety. She decided that she wasn't going to say anything to the Krauthers. They would have to do all the talking and respect her choice to remain silent. A friend urged Tanya to reconsider, reminding her that it was the Krauthers' son who had saved her life. Meeting each other was a gift for all those involved. Tanya went ahead with the meeting and the Krauthers immediately embraced her. While they sensed Tanya's apprehension, they spoke to her as if they were longtime friends. Tanya sat quietly as the Krauthers recounted stories of Wells,
欠他们儿子一条命的人那里听到消息。会面当天，坦尼娅再次被焦虑淹没。她决定什么都不对克劳瑟夫妇说。他们必须承担所有的谈话，并尊重她保持沉默的选择。一位朋友敦促坦尼娅重新考虑，提醒她正是克劳瑟夫妇的儿子救了她的命。见面对于所有相关人员来说都是一份礼物。坦尼娅继续进行了会面，克劳瑟夫妇立即拥抱了她。虽然他们感觉到了坦尼娅的忧虑，但他们像对待老朋友一样与她交谈。坦尼娅静静地坐着，听着克劳瑟夫妇讲述韦尔斯的故事，
from his interests and hobbies to the close relationship he had with his two sisters. Tanya told the couple that Wells sounded a lot like the man she married. With that, her defences came down and she told them her story. She spoke of how Wells had found her and led her to the stairwell, of the words they shared and his kind eyes. Jeff and Alison were moved to tears. Before they went their separate ways, they gave Tanya a gift, a red bandana. The Krauthers asked Tanya to speak at a memorial event for their son later that year.
从他的兴趣和爱好，到他与两个姐妹的亲密关系。坦尼娅告诉这对夫妇，韦尔斯听起来很像她嫁的那个男人。有了这句话，她的防线崩溃了，她向他们讲述了自己的故事。她讲述了韦尔斯是如何找到她并带她去楼梯间的，讲述了他们分享的话语和他善良的眼睛。杰夫和艾莉森感动得热泪盈眶。在他们分道扬镳之前，他们给了坦尼娅一份礼物：一条红头巾。克劳瑟夫妇请坦尼娅在当年晚些时候为他们的儿子举行的纪念活动上发言。
She told other survivors that she didn't want to, but felt like she couldn't refuse. The group was surprised by her cool indifference toward the Crowther family. Not only was it unlike Tanya to be dispassionate and impolite, she'd had no qualms telling her story in the past. Ever since the Ground Zero walking to her with the politicians, Tanya's fellow survivors had noticed a shift in her attitude. Her grace and optimism were often overshadowed by frustration, anxiety and indignation. She was prone to snapping at members of the Survivors' Network
她告诉其他幸存者她不想去，但觉得无法拒绝。团队对她对克劳瑟一家的冷漠感到惊讶。坦尼娅不仅一向不是那种冷漠无礼的人，而且她过去在讲述自己的故事时也从不犹豫。自从与政客们一起进行“零地带”徒步游览以来，坦尼娅的幸存者同伴们注意到她的态度发生了转变。她的优雅和乐观常常被沮丧、焦虑和愤慨所掩盖。她很容易对“幸存者网络”的成员发火，
and fostering animosity within the community. While she'd typically gone out of her way to help other survivors, she was now dismissive of them, as though her story was the only one that mattered. She began exuding arrogance, and network members were getting fed up, with some even leaving the group as a result. Tanya went from fronting intimate survivors meetings
并在社区内煽动敌意。虽然她过去通常会不遗余力地帮助其他幸存者，但现在她对他们不屑一顾，仿佛只有她的故事才重要。她开始表现出傲慢，网络成员对此感到厌倦，一些人甚至因此退出了该组织。坦尼娅从主持私密的幸存者会议，
to being invited to a wide range of heavily publicised 9-11 related events, from charity walks, to testifying at a congressional hearing. Whenever she expressed a desire to step back from the spotlight, she realized the days of anonymity were gone. The Ground Zero tours were taking place six times a day, seven days a week, and her story was reaching people from all around the world. Everyone knew Tanya Head. On the day of Wells Crowther's memorial event, Tanya was in such a state of panic that one of her friends had to escort her to the lecten
变成了受邀参加各种广受宣传的“9·11”相关活动，从慈善步行到在国会听证会上作证。每当她表达想要远离聚光灯的愿望时，她意识到匿名的日子已经一去不复返了。“零地带”的游览每天进行六次，每周七天，她的故事传遍了世界各地。每个人都知道坦尼娅·黑德。在韦尔斯·克劳瑟纪念活动当天，坦尼娅处于极度恐慌的状态，以至于她的一位朋友不得不护送她到讲台，
and give the speech on her behalf. Speaking of the struggle she'd had preparing for the event, Tanya's speech said, What exactly do you say to the family of the man who saved your life and gave his in the process? But then I thought about what Wals would do if our roles were reversed. and he was asked to do this for me.
并代表她发表演讲。谈到她为准备这次活动所做的挣扎，坦尼娅的演讲说：“你到底该对那个救了你的命，并在过程中献出自己生命的人的家人说些什么呢？但后来我想到，如果我们的角色互换，韦尔斯被要求为我做这件事，他会怎么做。”
This is what gave me the strength to be here today. In her speech, Tanya revealed that she told Wells' story to her family every Christmas to honour and preserve his memory. She also kept a picture of him in every room of her home, so he was always with her. Tanya's speech ended. In many ways, I feel Wells and I keep each other alive. Wells, you are my hero. I live my life to make you proud. Tanya Head's story boosted the Survivor's Network out of obscurity, and by 2007, it was a powerful and respected advocacy group
“这就是给我力量今天站在这里的原因。”在演讲中，坦尼娅透露，她每年圣诞节都会向家人讲述韦尔斯的故事，以纪念和保存他的记忆。她还在家里的每个房间都放了一张他的照片，这样他就永远和她在一起。坦尼娅的演讲结束了。“在很多方面，我觉得韦尔斯和我让彼此活着。韦尔斯，你是我的英雄。我活着是为了让你感到骄傲。”坦尼娅·黑德的故事让“幸存者网络”摆脱了默默无闻，到2007年，它已成为一个强大且受人尊敬的倡导组织，
with thousands of members. Tanya was given the role of president, a position created just for her. With all the good she'd done, she was seen as the perfect person to feature in a New York Times article for the upcoming sixth anniversary of 9-11. Tanya agreed to participate, but when it came time to sit down with the journalist, she cancelled and began ignoring their calls. Tanya told other members of the group that she didn't want to make the network all about her,
拥有数千名成员。坦尼娅被赋予了主席的角色，这是一个专门为她设立的职位。鉴于她所做的一切好事，她被视为即将到来的“9·11”六周年纪念日《纽约时报》文章的完美人选。坦尼娅同意参与，但当轮到与记者坐下来谈话时，她取消了预约并开始无视他们的电话。坦尼娅告诉该组织的其他成员，她不想让网络的一切都围绕着她，
but to them, it was clear that something else was going on. Ever since the article request, Tanya had been visibly irritated. She began skipping events and acting increasingly hostile and cruel to those around her. Some feared she was heading towards a mental breakdown. Tanya blamed the stress of the New York Times article for her recent behavior and said she no longer wanted to go ahead with it. But the journalist, David Dunlap, started contacting other survivors and asking some strange questions that had nothing to do with Tanya's survival story.
但对他们来说，很明显还有其他事情在发生。自从文章请求发出以来，坦尼娅一直明显很烦躁。她开始缺席活动，并对周围的人表现得越来越敌对和残忍。一些人担心她正走向精神崩溃。坦尼娅将她最近的行为归咎于《纽约时报》文章带来的压力，并表示她不再想继续进行下去了。但记者戴维·邓拉普（David Dunlap）开始联系其他幸存者，并提出了一些奇怪的问题，这些问题与坦尼娅的幸存故事毫无关系。
Had they ever been to her apartment or seen pictures of her fiancé? Tanya accused David Dunlap of stalking and harassing her as revenge for rejecting his interview offers. He apologised for upsetting her, saying he was just interested to know why she was so reluctant to speak with him. Tanya's supporters asked David to email through his questions instead so that Tanya could answer them in her own time. He immediately sent through two pages worth. His questions covered everything from where Tanya had gone to school to whether she was still employed by Merrill Lynch. He also wanted to clarify whether Tanya had been engaged or married at the time of the 9-11 attacks, as she'd referred to her deceased partner as both her fiancé and husband.
他们去过她的公寓吗？见过她未婚夫的照片吗？坦尼娅指责戴维·邓拉普跟踪和骚扰她，作为拒绝他采访请求的报复。他为让她心烦意乱而道歉，说他只是想知道为什么她如此不愿与他交谈。坦尼娅的支持者要求戴维通过电子邮件发送他的问题，以便坦尼娅可以在她自己的时间回答。他立即发送了两页纸的内容。他的问题涵盖了从坦尼娅在哪里上学到她是否仍受雇于美林证券（Merrill Lynch）的所有内容。他还想澄清坦尼娅在“9·11”袭击时是否已经订婚或结婚，因为她曾将她已故的伴侣称为她的未婚夫和丈夫。
There were also questions about what hospital Tanya had been treated in after 9-11. and if a doctor or nurse there could attest to her remarkable recovery. The question sent Tanya into a fit of rage to the dismay of other members of the network. If she didn't want to answer the questions herself, they suggested she passed them on to her in-laws or her employer, or give the journalist the names of the people from her story who could corroborate her version of events. Tanya refused. As the pressure to participate in the article mounted, she confessed to the real reason she was avoiding the New York Times.
还有关于坦尼娅在“9·11”之后在哪个医院接受治疗的问题，以及那里的医生或护士是否能证明她非凡的康复过程。这些问题让坦尼娅陷入了狂怒，令网络其他成员感到沮丧。如果她不想自己回答这些问题，他们建议她把问题转交给她的姻亲或雇主，或者给记者提供她故事中那些能证实她版本事件的人的名字。坦尼娅拒绝了。随着参与文章的压力越来越大，她承认了她回避《纽约时报》的真正原因。
She wasn't a US citizen. This only confused survivors more. Given her prominence and respectability in the country, they were certain no one would care. The day before the article was scheduled to drop, Tanya sent an email to the Survivors Network that read, As you know, the New York Times is going to publish an article about me. I ask all of you to please not listen to what is in the article,
她不是美国公民。这只会让幸存者更加困惑。鉴于她在国内的显赫地位和受人尊敬的程度，他们确信没人会在意。在文章定于发布的前一天，坦尼娅给“幸存者网络”发了一封电子邮件，上面写着：“如你们所知，《纽约时报》将发表一篇关于我的文章。我请求你们所有人请不要听文章里写了什么，
but reflect upon what you know of me. On Thursday, September 27, 2007, the article appeared on the front page of the New York Times with the title. In a 9-11 survival tale, the pieces just don't fit. It began. Tanya Head's story, as shared over the years with reporters, students, friends, and hundreds of visitors to Ground Zero was a remarkable account of both life and death.
而是反思你们所了解的我。”2007年9月27日星期四，这篇文章出现在《纽约时报》的头版，标题为《在“9·11”幸存故事中，碎片就是拼凑不上》。文章开头写道：“坦尼娅·黑德的故事，多年来与记者、学生、朋友和数百名‘零地带’游客分享，是一个关于生与死的非凡叙述。”
But no part of her story, it turns out, has been verified. Journalist David Dunlap had done his due diligence when it came to every claim Tanya had made over the past few years, and he'd discovered that nothing added up. Harvard and Stanford universities had no records of a student called Tanya Head, nor had Merrill Lynch ever employed someone by that name. Tanya didn't have an office in the World Trade Center, and there was also no proof that she'd gone to Southeast Asia in 2005 to perform humanitarian work.
“但事实证明，她故事的任何部分都没有得到证实。”记者戴维·邓拉普在处理坦尼娅过去几年所做的每一项声明时都尽职尽责，他发现一切都对不上。哈佛大学和斯坦福大学都没有名为坦尼娅·黑德的学生记录，美林证券也从未雇佣过这个名字的人。坦尼娅在世界贸易中心没有办公室，也没有证据表明她在2005年去过东南亚进行人道主义工作。
The truth about Tanya's fiancé, David, was a little more complex to unravel. There was indeed a man named David who had died in the same. North Tower. Everything about him matched with Tanya's description of her deceased partner, from his age to his job, to the fact that he was a likable outdoorsman who loved to travel, write poetry, and volunteered at a soup kitchen. But when contacted prior to the release of the New York Times article, David's family, friends and colleagues, all said they'd never heard of Tanya head. David hadn't been engaged, had never travelled to Hawaii, and he lived with roommates, not a girlfriend.
关于坦尼娅的未婚夫戴维的真相要复杂一些。确实有一个名叫戴维的男人死在同一座北塔。关于他的一切都与坦尼娅对她已故伴侣的描述相符，从他的年龄到他的工作，再到他是一个喜欢旅行、写诗并在慈善食堂做志愿者的讨人喜欢的户外运动爱好者。但在《纽约时报》文章发布前联系时，戴维的家人、朋友和同事都说他们从未听说过坦尼娅·黑德。戴维没有订婚，从未去过夏威夷，而且他与室友同住，而不是与女朋友。
According to the New York Times article, quote, Few people, it seems, who embraced the gripping immediacy and pain of Tanya's account, ever asked the name of the man whose ring she had returned, or that of the hospital where she was treated, or the identities of the people she met with in the South Tower on the morning of 9-11. Journalist David Dunlap explained that he couldn't find a single person who recalled encountering Tanya Head at the World Trade Center on 9-11. While Tanya had told dramatic stories about the family members of victims, the only ones
根据《纽约时报》的文章，引用：“似乎很少有人在拥抱坦尼娅叙述的扣人心弦的紧迫感和痛苦时，会问她归还戒指的那个男人的名字，或者她接受治疗的医院，或者她在“9·11”那天早上在南塔会见的人的身份。”记者戴维·邓拉普解释说，他找不到任何一个人记得在“9·11”那天在世界贸易中心遇到过坦尼娅·黑德。虽然坦尼娅讲述了关于受害者家属的戏剧性故事，但她唯一
she'd ever formally met were Jeff and Alison Crowther. The Crothers told David Dunlap that Tanya had promised to send them a piece of the scorched jacket she had worn on 9-11, as it was well. one of the last things their son had touched. She failed to deliver on that promise. She had also agreed to donate the jacket to a tribute centre that displayed 9-11 artifacts, but never followed through. Like the rest of America, the Krauthers were left stunned by Tanya's betrayal, and the way in which she'd exploited Wells' memory to fuel her deception. Jeff Crowther told the New York Times,
正式见过的人只有杰夫和艾莉森·克劳瑟。克劳瑟夫妇告诉戴维·邓拉普，坦尼娅曾承诺给他们寄一件她在“9·11”那天穿的烧焦的夹克，因为那是他们儿子最后接触的东西之一。她没有兑现那个承诺。她还同意将夹克捐赠给一个展示“9·11”文物的纪念中心，但从未付诸行动。像美国其他地方一样，克劳瑟夫妇被坦尼娅的背叛，以及她利用韦尔斯的记忆来助长她的欺骗的方式惊呆了。杰夫·克劳瑟告诉《纽约时报》，
She seemed so heartfelt and genuine. His wife Alison later told Channel 4, We took her on just complete trust and faith. We had no reason not to believe everything she was saying to us. It turned out that Tanya's real name was Alicia Estever Head. Born in Spain to a prominent and affluent family, she was the youngest of five children. As the only girl, Alicia was considered to be her parents' duel, and they gave her everything she wanted.
“她看起来如此真诚和坦率。”他的妻子艾莉森后来告诉第四频道（Channel 4）：“我们完全出于信任和信念接受了她。我们没有理由不相信她对我们所说的一切。”事实证明，坦尼娅的真名是艾丽西亚·埃斯特韦·黑德（Alicia Esteve Head）。她出生在西班牙一个显赫而富裕的家庭，是五个孩子中最小的一个。作为唯一的女孩，艾丽西亚被认为是她父母的掌上明珠，他们给了她想要的一切。
Her family split their time between three lavish homes, mingling with politicians and European royalty on yachts and at exclusive clubs. Alicia liked to boast about her family's wealth and social position, her expensive clothes, and her top-tier education. That was until 1992, when her father and brother were embroiled in a highly publicised multi-million dollar financial scandal. Both wound up in jail for embezzlement, bringing shame to their family's name. Alicia distanced herself from the men in her family and desperately tried to regain her pride and honour. She focused on her career, hoping to establish herself as an influential and respected businesswoman.
她的家人在三处豪华住宅之间轮流居住，在游艇和高级俱乐部里与政客和欧洲皇室成员交往。艾丽西亚喜欢吹嘘她家庭的财富和社会地位、她昂贵的衣服和她顶级的教育。直到1992年，她的父亲和兄弟卷入了一场广为人知的数百万美元金融丑闻。两人最终因贪污入狱，给家族名声带来了耻辱。艾丽西亚与家里的男性保持距离，拼命试图重获她的骄傲和荣誉。她专注于自己的事业，希望将自己确立为一位有影响力且受人尊敬的女商人。
Her fierce ambition made her notably ruthless. Alicia was known to pick co-workers against each other so that she could get ahead, and she surrounded herself with people who didn't overshadow her. She was also known for being generous in a way that made others feel as though she was buying their friendship. Throughout her childhood, Alicia was known to lie to get attention and boost her self-esteem. As she got older, that behaviour escalated. She typically made up stories whenever she felt frustrated or bored with her life.
她强烈的野心使她显得格外冷酷。艾丽西亚以挑拨同事关系以求晋升而闻名，她身边围绕着那些不会掩盖她光芒的人。她还以一种让别人觉得她在购买友谊的方式慷慨大方。在整个童年时期，艾丽西亚就以撒谎来博取关注和提升自尊而闻名。随着年龄的增长，这种行为升级了。每当她感到沮丧或对生活感到厌倦时，她通常会编造故事。
They were mostly just harmless fibs centred around fictitious boyfriends. The lengths of her deception took a dramatic turn in September 2001. While Alicia claimed to have been working in the World Trade Centre when the September 11 attacks took place, The reality was that she had been in Barcelona, where she was enrolled in a master's program at a university specialising in economics. There was no record of her taking a leave of absence around that time, nor did any of her classmates recall her sporting any injuries. The damage to Alicia's right arm was the result of a previous accident, though exactly what caused
这些大多是围绕虚构男友的无害谎言。她欺骗的程度在2001年9月发生了戏剧性的转变。虽然艾丽西亚声称在“9·11”袭击发生时在世界贸易中心工作，但现实是她当时在巴塞罗那，在那里她就读于一所专门研究经济学的大学的硕士课程。没有记录显示她在那个时候请过假，她的同学也不记得她受过任何伤。艾丽西亚右臂的损伤是之前事故的结果，尽管究竟是什么原因造成的
it remained up for debate. To some, Alicia said that. that she'd been driving in a Ferrari with her fiancé, traveling at 200 kilometres an hour, when the vehicle crashed. Alicia's right arm was severed and needed to be reattached, while her fiancée died as a result. She told others the injury was caused by a horse riding accident at a polo country club. As one Spanish journalist later recounted to Channel 4, Alicia Restavee Head was a very good actress, because,
仍然存在争议。对一些人，艾丽西亚说她和未婚夫坐在一辆法拉利里，以每小时200公里的速度行驶时，车辆发生了碰撞。艾丽西亚的右臂被切断并需要重新接上，而她的未婚夫因此死亡。她告诉其他人，伤势是由马球乡村俱乐部的骑马事故造成的。正如一位西班牙记者后来向第四频道讲述的那样，艾丽西亚·埃斯特韦·黑德是一位非常好的演员，因为，
With all these lies, I never found anyone telling me, I didn't believe her. Alicia graduated in May 2002, telling her classmates that Barcelona wasn't big enough for her dreams. It was no secret that Alicia had been obsessed with America from a young age. She learned American English, traveled to the States often, and had an American flag on her bedroom wall. It therefore came as no surprise to those who knew her when she depotable. parted for New York City, where she started going by the name Tanya. In hindsight, it was clear that Tanya's fictitious 9-11 survival story was woven from genuine reports, as everything she'd detailed about the day was factually correct. It appeared that she'd undertaken extensive research
“有了这些谎言，我从来没发现有人告诉我，我不相信她。”艾丽西亚于2002年5月毕业，告诉同学巴塞罗那容不下她的梦想。艾丽西亚从小就痴迷于美国，这已不是什么秘密。她学习美式英语，经常去美国旅行，卧室墙上挂着一面美国国旗。因此，当她动身前往纽约市，并开始使用坦尼娅这个名字时，那些认识她的人并不感到惊讶。事后看来，很明显，坦尼娅虚构的“9·11”幸存故事是由真实的报道编织而成的，因为她详细描述的关于那一天的每一件事在事实上都是正确的。看来她进行了广泛的研究，
before first presenting herself to the online survivor community in May 2003. With the truth about Tanya Head coming to light, criticism was directed at the media for not fact-checking Tanya's claims before printing them. But, as the Morning Call newspaper pointed out, Tanya Head managed to rope in a traumatized group of survivors, a traumatized city and a traumatized nation, because she lied about something that, in most people's imagination, nobody would dare lie about. Still, Tanya had drawn a degree of suspicion over the years. Some found it odd that Tanya had never shown them any photos of her and her fiancé David together. When they visited Tanya's apartment, the golden retriever named Elvis that she and David had apparently bought together was always out on walks. Tanya had promised
在2003年5月首次向在线幸存者社区展示自己之前。随着坦尼娅·黑德的真相大白，媒体因在印刷前没有核实坦尼娅的说法而受到批评。但是，正如《晨报》（Morning Call）指出的那样，坦尼娅·黑德成功地欺骗了一群受创伤的幸存者、一个受创伤的城市和一个受创伤的国家，因为她撒谎的事情，在大多数人的想象中，没人敢撒谎。尽管如此，坦尼娅多年来还是引起了一定程度的怀疑。有些人觉得奇怪，坦尼娅从未向他们展示过她和未婚夫戴维在一起的照片。当他们去坦尼娅的公寓时，她和戴维显然一起买的那只名叫埃尔维斯（Elvis）的金毛猎犬总是出去散步。坦尼娅曾承诺
to take some of her survivor friends to the Hampton Beach House where David's belongings were allegedly stored, but she kept cancelling at the last minute. One, had been driven to search David's name online, but found no mention of him being engaged or married at all. While some had felt uneasy about Tanya's claims, they'd been unsure of how to address it. Tanya had a tendency to get emotional whenever someone asked about her ordeal, and they didn't want to pry and make things worse. Others were acutely aware of Tanya's influence and power among the Survivor's Network, and they didn't want to risk being kicked out of the community they relied on for support. The fear of Tanya was justified. A 9-11 survivor named Lisa once attended a charity
带她的一些幸存者朋友去汉普顿海滩别墅，戴维的遗物据称存放在那里，但她总是在最后一刻取消。有人曾被驱使在网上搜索戴维的名字，但发现根本没有提到他订婚或结婚。虽然有些人对坦尼娅的说法感到不安，但他们不确定该如何处理。每当有人问起她的磨难时，坦尼娅往往会变得情绪化，他们不想打听并让事情变得更糟。其他人敏锐地意识到坦尼娅在“幸存者网络”中的影响力和权力，他们不想冒被踢出他们赖以生存的社区的风险。对坦尼娅的恐惧是有道理的。一位名叫丽莎（Lisa）的“9·11”幸存者曾参加过一次慈善
event with Tanya, who wore a t-shirt that bore a photo of her fiancé David. Lisa immediately recognized him as one of her colleagues. She was surprised to learn that David had been engaged. He'd never once mentioned it at work. Lisa tried to speak to Tanya about their mutual connection, but Tanya became dismissive, saying it was too painful to talk about. After that, Tanya turned the Survivors Network against Lisa, and she was no longer welcome in the group. A similar thing happened to the Survivors Network founder Jerry Bogas.
活动，坦尼娅穿着一件印有她未婚夫戴维照片的T恤。丽莎立即认出他是她的同事之一。她很惊讶地得知戴维订婚了。他在工作中从未提过。丽莎试图与坦尼娅谈论他们的共同联系，但坦尼娅变得不屑一顾，说谈论这件事太痛苦了。在那之后，坦尼娅煽动“幸存者网络”反对丽莎，她不再受欢迎。类似的事情也发生在“幸存者网络”创始人杰里·博加斯身上。
After years of close friendship, Tanya abruptly started campaigning against us. to Jerry, saying he no longer had the tenacity or leadership skills to front the group. Jerry couldn't believe what was happening. The kind and selfless Tanya he once knew had become mean-spirited and calculating. She convinced the Survivor's Network to remove Jerry, and was then promoted to president. Jerry was devastated. It wasn't until Tanya was exposed as a fraud that he realized why she must have suddenly turned on him. Driven by a mix of curiosity and suspicion, Jerry had asked Tanya for her fiancé's last name. He then checked it against the 9-11 victim list and confirmed it was there. Satisfied with these findings, Jerry moved on. But it was shortly after
在多年的亲密友谊之后，坦尼娅突然开始针对杰里进行运动，说他不再具备领导该团体的坚韧或领导能力。杰里无法相信正在发生的事情。他曾经认识的那个善良无私的坦尼娅已经变得刻薄和工于心计。她劝说“幸存者网络”罢免了杰里，随后被提升为主席。杰里崩溃了。直到坦尼娅被揭露为骗子，他才意识到她为什么会突然对他下手。出于好奇和怀疑，杰里曾向坦尼娅询问她未婚夫的姓氏。然后他将其与“9·11”受害者名单进行了核对，并确认它在上面。对这些发现感到满意后，杰里继续前行。但就在不久之后，
this that Tanya pushed to have him removed from the network. Before the release of the New York Times, article, journalist David Dunlap had only been able to get one quote from Tanya. On a phone call, two days before the article went to print, Tanya stated, I have done nothing illegal. She wasn't wrong. Under American law, for Tanya to be charged with fraud, she would have had to deceptively obtain property from another person for her own benefit. During her time with the Survivor, network, investigations revealed that Tanya didn't earn or take anything. All her work was unpaid, and she had only ever donated her own money to the cause, and large amounts of it. Authorities were powerless. While Tanya's actions were clearly immoral, they weren't illegal.
坦尼娅推动将他从网络中除名。在《纽约时报》文章发布之前，记者戴维·邓拉普只从坦尼娅那里得到了一句引语。在文章付印前两天的电话中，坦尼娅说：“我没有做任何违法的事情。”她没说错。根据美国法律，要以欺诈罪起诉坦尼娅，她必须为了自己的利益欺骗性地从他人那里获取财产。在她在“幸存者网络”期间，调查显示坦尼娅没有赚取或拿走任何东西。她所有的工作都是无偿的，她只为事业捐赠过自己的钱，而且数额巨大。当局无能为力。虽然坦尼娅的行为显然是不道德的，但它们并不违法。
For years, filmmaker Angelo Guglielmo had been working directly with Tanya Head to create a documentary about the survivors of 9-11. In the aftermath of the New York Times article, Angelo headed to Tanya's apartment seeking an explanation. He found her looking disheveled and overcome with rage and self-pity. She blamed her situation on the media, asserting they were out to get her. She was also bitter that the Survivors' Network had turned on her
多年来，电影制作人安杰洛·古列尔莫（Angelo Guglielmo）一直与坦尼娅·黑德直接合作，制作一部关于“9·11”幸存者的纪录片。《纽约时报》文章发表后，安杰洛前往坦尼娅的公寓寻求解释。他发现她看起来衣衫不整，被愤怒和自怜所淹没。她将自己的处境归咎于媒体，断言他们想对付她。她还对“幸存者网络”背叛她感到痛苦，
after everything she'd done for them. Her membership had been revoked, and the role of president had been assigned to another member. No one in the group had reached out to Tanya, and several had publicly expressed their indignation. Tanya showed no remorse, telling Angelo, How could they say all these terrible things about me? What kind of friends are these?
在她为他们做了那么多之后。她的会员资格已被撤销，主席一职已被分配给另一名成员。团队中没有人联系过坦尼娅，几个人公开表达了他们的愤慨。坦尼娅没有表现出悔意，告诉安杰洛：“他们怎么能说所有这些关于我的可怕事情？这是什么样的朋友？”
Realising Tanya wasn't going to admit to anything, Angelo left. unsure what to do with his documentary in light of the recent revelations, he discussed the matter with the Survivor's Network. They agreed that Angelo should finish the project while also highlighting everything Tanya did, both good and bad. When Tanya found out about it, she was furious. She phoned Angelo, warning. One day the truth will come out and you'll all feel terrible and apologised to me. After the release of the New York Times article, Tanya attempted to reach out to a few friends via email, but only one was willing to talk. They were surprised to find that she
意识到坦尼娅不会承认任何事情，安杰洛离开了。鉴于最近的披露，他不确定该如何处理他的纪录片，他与“幸存者网络”讨论了此事。他们同意安杰洛应该完成这个项目，同时强调坦尼娅所做的一切，无论好坏。当坦尼娅发现这件事时，她非常愤怒。她打电话给安杰洛，警告说：“总有一天真相会大白，你们所有人都会感到非常糟糕，并向我道歉。”《纽约时报》文章发布后，坦尼娅试图通过电子邮件联系几个朋友，但只有一个愿意交谈。他们惊讶地发现她
was unapologetic and depicted herself as the victim. After this, Tanya more or less vanished. She maintained sporadic contact with a few people, saying she was moving to a new apartment, had a new job and was working with a therapist. When members of the Survivor's Network received a mysterious email from a Spanish account alleging that Tanya Head had taken her own life, they were skeptical. They believed Tanya had sent the email herself. Three years later, on Thursday, December 23, 2010, Angelo Gulelemo was in New York when he spotted Tanya out of the corner of his eye.
毫无悔意，并将自己描绘成受害者。此后，坦尼娅几乎消失了。她与少数人保持着断断续续的联系，说她要搬到新公寓，有了新工作，并正在接受治疗师的治疗。当“幸存者网络”的成员收到一封来自西班牙账户的神秘电子邮件，声称坦尼娅·黑德已经自杀时，他们持怀疑态度。他们认为坦尼娅是自己发送的邮件。三年后，2010年12月23日星期四，安杰洛·古列尔莫在纽约时，眼角余光瞥见了坦尼娅。
He rushed over, put his hand on her shoulder and said her name. Stardled, Tanya jumped back and yelled. Get away from me, don't speak to me. She gave Angelo the middle finger and took off. Angelo was so shocked that he walked away. He later regretted that he didn't press Tanya for answers. Nine months later on Wednesday, September 14, 2011, Angelo was walking down the street when Tanya obliviously passed by him again.
他冲过去，把手放在她的肩膀上，叫了她的名字。坦尼娅吓了一跳，跳开并大喊：“离我远点，别跟我说话。”她向安杰洛竖起中指，然后跑开了。安杰洛非常震惊，以至于他走开了。他后来后悔没有逼问坦尼娅。九个月后，2011年9月14日星期三，安杰洛走在街上时，坦尼娅又无意中从他身边经过。
Shaking with nerves, Angelo retrieved his camera from his backpack and began following her. Tanya was with her mother, who'd previously insisted she didn't know a thing about her daughter's deception. The pair headed to the East River where they stopped to admire the sunset. Tanya looked happy and carefree. Angelo continued to follow Tanya as she entered a boutique hotel. Angelo waited outside, mulling over what he should do next. Two hours later, Tanya reappeared alone and dressed for a party. As she walked towards a bus stop, Angelo became overwhelmed with anger.
安杰洛紧张得发抖，从背包里拿出相机开始跟踪她。坦尼娅和她的母亲在一起，她母亲之前坚称对女儿的欺骗一无所知。两人前往东河，在那里停下来欣赏日落。坦尼娅看起来很高兴，无忧无虑。安杰洛继续跟踪坦尼娅，直到她进入一家精品酒店。安杰洛在外面等着，琢磨着接下来该做什么。两个小时后，坦尼娅独自出现，盛装打扮准备去参加派对。当她走向公交车站时，安杰洛被愤怒淹没了。
He headed towards her with his camera rolling. As soon as Tanya recognized Angelo, she started shaking her head. and her body stiffened. Don't come near me, Angelo, she ordered. Get away from me. Angelo didn't stop filming. Tanya reached out for the camera, at which point Angelo exploded, yelling,
他带着摄像机向她走去。当坦尼娅认出安杰洛时，她开始摇头，身体僵硬了。“别靠近我，安杰洛，”她命令道。“离我远点。”安杰洛没有停止拍摄。坦尼娅伸手去拿相机，这时安杰洛爆发了，大喊：
How dare you? Don't you have any feelings for the people you've hurt? Tanya, don't you have any feelings at all? Tanya pulled out her mobile phone and said she was calling the police. Angelo turned off his camera and walked away. Reflecting on the experience, he later said, I took no pleasure in that encounter. That night, I replayed the video and cringed.
“你怎么敢？你对那些被你伤害的人没有一点感觉吗？坦尼娅，你难道一点感觉都没有吗？”坦尼娅拿出手机说她要报警。安杰洛关掉相机走开了。反思这次经历，他后来表示：“那次遭遇我没有任何快感。那天晚上，我重播了视频，感到畏缩。”
I felt sad and sorry. Did that mean I forgave her? Who the hell knows? I didn't even know who she was. Angelo's documentary on the Survivor's Network and Tanya Head was released in 2012 with the name, The Woman Who Wasn't There. He also co-wrote a book with the same title. Since her fall from Grace, Tanja Head has remained out of the public eye.
“我感到悲伤和遗憾。那意味着我原谅她了吗？谁知道呢？我甚至不知道她是谁。”安杰洛关于“幸存者网络”和坦尼娅·黑德的纪录片于2012年发行，名为《不在场的人》（The Woman Who Wasn't There）。他还合著了一本同名书籍。自从她跌落神坛以来，坦尼娅·黑德一直远离公众视线。
Aside from fleeting sightings in New York, it is believed she returned to Barcelona to live with her mother. In recent times, her name and image was used for an account on the professional networking platform LinkedIn. The profile matches Tanya's biography and claims she is working and living in New York. Efforts to verify this information have come up dry. Given that Tanya never claimed any accountability for her fake 9-11 survival story, the question still remains. Why did she do it? Some believe Tanya showed signs of pseudologia fantastica, a rare syndrome where individuals, represent certain fantasies as real occurrences. It manifests in several ways that include
除了在纽约偶尔被瞥见外，据信她回到了巴塞罗那与母亲同住。最近，她的名字和形象被用于专业社交平台LinkedIn上的一个账户。该个人资料与坦尼娅的传记相符，并声称她在纽约工作和生活。核实此信息的努力均无果而终。鉴于坦尼娅从未对她虚假的“9·11”幸存故事承担任何责任，问题依然存在。她为什么要这样做？有些人认为坦尼娅表现出了“虚构症”（pseudologia fantastica）的迹象，这是一种罕见的综合征，个人将某些幻想表现为真实事件。它以多种方式表现出来，包括
chronic lying with no clear objective benefit, dramatic, detailed, complicated and colourful storytelling geared to achieve acceptance, admiration and sympathy. The stories themselves feature the teller as a hero or victim. During her time with the Survivor's Network, Tanya had started writing about her experience as though she intended to release a book. One passage read, It's still all so raw. It hurts as much now as then, and I still cannot understand why, why, why. I talked to Dave and told him I was sorry, but he didn't answer back. Our photos together are ghosts of a life I once had, and desperately
没有明确客观利益的慢性撒谎，旨在获得接受、钦佩和同情的戏剧性、详细、复杂和丰富多彩的故事讲述。故事本身将讲述者描绘成英雄或受害者。在“幸存者网络”期间，坦尼娅开始撰写关于她的经历，仿佛她打算出版一本书。其中一段写道：“这一切仍然如此生硬。现在和当时一样痛苦，我仍然无法理解为什么，为什么，为什么。我和戴夫谈过，告诉他我很抱歉，但他没有回答。我们在一起的照片是我曾经拥有的生活的鬼魂，我拼命地……”
want back. My other harp is missing, ripped away from us by human missiles. One reporter who read Tanya's writing said, It's such bullshit. I mean now I look at it and now go, wow, it's amazing. She constructed a very large narrative, a big, big story. Documentary filmmaker Angelo Guglielmo told NPR, It was clear to me right away that Tanya did it for the attention, for some crazy need to be a star.
想要回来。我的另一把竖琴不见了，被人类的导弹从我们身边夺走了。一位读过坦尼娅文章的记者说，这简直是胡扯。我的意思是，现在我回过头来看，觉得哇，这太不可思议了。她构建了一个非常宏大的叙事，一个非常非常大的故事。纪录片制作人安杰洛·古列尔莫告诉美国国家公共电台，我很清楚，坦尼娅这样做是为了博取关注，出于某种想成为明星的疯狂需求。
That's what she wanted to be, and she became that. One US psychologist stated that Tanya had, wanted what most liars want, which is to change the way other people look at them, to be loved and respected and valued and cared about. Speaking to Channel 4 about his own theory, Jeff Krauthar said, It would appear to me that she is an individual with a low self-esteem, very low self-esteem. She felt she needed to do something to create a different Tanya. While Tanya Head had escaped punishment, her actions had a lasting impact on the genuine survivors of 9-11.
这就是她想成为的人，她也确实做到了。一位美国心理学家指出，坦尼娅想要的是大多数撒谎者想要的东西，那就是改变别人看待他们的方式，想要被爱、被尊重、被重视和被关心。杰夫·克劳萨在接受第四频道采访时谈到了他自己的理论，他说，在我看来，她是一个自尊心很低的人，自尊心非常低。她觉得她需要做点什么来创造一个不同的坦尼娅。虽然坦尼娅·黑德逃脱了惩罚，但她的行为对9·11事件的真正幸存者产生了持久的影响。
Before Tanya was exposed as a fraud, her ability to triumph in the face of adversity caused others to harbour guilt and shame about their struggles. Many felt their own experience was nothing compared to what Tanya had gone through, and they therefore hesitated to share their stories. Many also felt they weren't doing enough to help the Survivors Network when Tanya was doing so much despite all she'd suffered through. In reality, the reason she was able to put so much time and energy into the network, because she wasn't dealing with any real trauma like the rest of the members were. Once the truth came out, members of the network felt embarrassed for being duped.
在坦尼娅被揭穿是骗子之前，她在逆境中获胜的能力让其他人对自己的挣扎感到内疚和羞愧。许多人觉得与坦尼娅所经历的一切相比，他们自己的经历根本不算什么，因此他们犹豫是否要分享自己的故事。许多人还觉得，当坦尼娅尽管遭受了那么多痛苦却做了那么多事情时，他们自己在帮助幸存者网络方面做得还不够。事实上，她之所以能投入那么多时间和精力在网络上，是因为她不像其他成员那样需要处理任何真正的创伤。真相大白后，网络成员们为自己被愚弄感到尴尬。
Many of them idolized Tanya, but with her deception exposed, they felt like they'd lost another close friend to 9-11. One member said, I'm very torn. She did a lot of good for our network. It's hard to discredit it at all. But she didn't have to lie. She could have done those things without needing to lie.
他们中的许多人崇拜坦尼娅，但随着她的欺骗行为被揭露，他们感觉自己又失去了一位因9·11事件而离世的亲密朋友。一位成员说，我非常纠结。她为我们的网络做了很多好事。很难完全否定这一点。但她没必要撒谎。她本可以在不需要撒谎的情况下做这些事情。
The group's founder, Jerry Bogas, told Channel 4 that there was a violence to Tanya's actions. It's taking advantage of people, he said. And if you take advantage of people, he said. particularly vulnerable people, that's even worse. During her time in the network, Tanya had received counselling from a therapist who was fully convinced of her story. Reflecting back, the therapist said, It's a case study. It's not just a window into her personality and what she was capable of, but of what was going on with the whole 9-11 community and what they were feeling.
该组织的创始人杰里·博加斯告诉第四频道，坦尼娅的行为具有暴力性。他说，这是在利用人们。他说，如果你利用人们，特别是那些脆弱的人，那就更糟糕了。在她在网络期间，坦尼娅曾接受过一位完全相信她故事的治疗师的咨询。回想起来，这位治疗师说，这是一个案例研究。它不仅是了解她个性和她能力的一个窗口，也是了解整个9·11社区正在发生什么以及他们感受的一个窗口。
The survivors needed and wanted a Tanya so much that they helped create her. With Tanya gone, members of the Survivor's Network were free to speak openly without feeling inadequate. However, the damage was already done. Tanya's actions had fuelled suspicions in the group and members began accusing one another of being frauds and lying. The group ultimately disbanded. When the truth was exposed, something Tenya Head had once said took on new meaning. Speaking of 9-11, Tanya remarked, Sometimes I have to go back and think,
幸存者们太需要也太想要一个坦尼娅了，以至于他们帮助创造了她。随着坦尼娅的离开，幸存者网络的成员们可以自由地公开交谈，而不会感到自卑。然而，伤害已经造成。坦尼娅的行为加剧了群体内部的怀疑，成员们开始指责彼此是骗子和撒谎者。该组织最终解散了。当真相大白时，坦尼娅·黑德曾经说过的一句话有了新的含义。在谈到9·11事件时，坦尼娅评论道，有时我不得不回过头去思考，
Was it real? Was it a dream? Was my life really like that? Or was it just all make-belief? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是真的吗？那是一场梦吗？我的生活真的是那样的吗？还是这一切都只是虚构的？本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。